The world outside of central Maine always never got to know Stephen King for his
wife's diligence.
Indeck confidence in her husband's the book that launched a million pages might
never have come into being when his wife Tabitha rescued the start of the
manuscripts of Carrie from the trash and insisted her husband finished.
His king was working as an English teacher and writing on the site.
Some of those judgements was absolutely right.
Carrie was a smash hit and Stephen King is now one of the world's most famous
and prolific authors.
So what's the story behind the stories?
Well,
that still even into his life,
Stephen King was born in Portland,
Maine,
the largest city of the mostly rural state that serves as the setting for so
many of his famous stories.
Steven was the second son born to Nellie ends,
Donald King,
but the family of four seam became a family of three when steven was only two
years old and his brother only for that father went out telling the family he
was buying a pack of cigarettes and he never returned.
King's mother worked several jobs moving with the boys from Maine and going from
state to state to falling into work and the place that she could afford to live
and raise our two boys,
but Maine,
it was home and it's where the family eventually settled for good.
When the family moved back to Maine,
they didn't have indoor plumbing,
and this was the 19 sixties king's life growing up.
It was a far cry from the wealth that he has now with King.
Didn't see his childhood as exceptional or out of the ordinary that he does
acknowledge.
He's always liked scary things.
My childhood was pretty ordinary.
Yeah,
except from a very early age.
I wanted to be scattered.
I just did.
I was scared afterwards.
I wanted to light on because I was scared.
There was something in the closet.
My imagination was very active.
Even at a young age.
Some have said that king might also be inspired to write such horrifying stories
by a childhood events.
He doesn't even remember.
According to mum,
I had gone off to play at a neighbor's house,
a house that was near a railroad line.
About an hour after I left,
I came back,
she says,
is white as a ghost.
I would not speak for the rest of the day.
I would not tell her why I'm not waiting to be picked up or phones that I wanted
to come home.
I would not tell her why chums,
mum hadn't walked me back,
but it allowed me to come alone.
It turns out that the kid I had been playing with had been run over by a freight
train while playing on or crossing the tracks.
Years later,
my mother told me they'd picked up the pieces in a wicker basket.
As True Isaac is that events Mr Bennett was not the only explanation for kings,
that vivid imagination of friends of the king's tell stories about how the
family was well known for their attention to literature.
If their mother couldn't find or afford a babysitter should leave her son's
alone with the expectation they would read aloud to each other.
Kings and love of stories and the written word was fostered from an early age
and that tradition,
it stuck.
Gang and his wife Tabitha also made their own children read aloud to each other
and to them he'd even record them on cassettes to make the family that own of
audio books growing up.
King also write material for his brother's newsletter called Dave's rag.
They made copies on a mimeograph machine and distributed it to their friends,
but king was unable to move me on just writing for his siblings and he was the
last up in 1965 when he was still in high school.
King was published in comics.
Review the story was right in line with the frightening plots that we all know
king for today can.
You had been working as a grave digger and money as a teenager.
The job inspired him to write a story called I was a teenage grave robbing and
its publication was his first taste of published success.
The only downside was that he didn't get paid for the work is first paid.
Publication didn't come until he was in college and he earns $35 for a story
called the glass floor.
Congratulated from Lisbon falls high school.
The high school in the town that later became the setting for portions of the
book,
11,
2163.
Lisbon falls was a mill town and King spent time working in the towns mill when
he was a teenager
after graduation.
King had aspirations to be a writeup,
so we headed north to the University of men or no to earn a degree in English
literature.
While in college,
King was a columnist for the college paper,
was outspoken against the Vietnam War and worked in the college library.
That's the library is now home to many of kings papers.
It's also where he met his wife,
Tabitha was looking for a book in the stacks and king passed by and struck up a
conversation with her and four years later the literary recouple had graduated,
had a daughter,
and they were married.
Woking had been rising in college.
He was far from being able to support himself and the growing family just by
writing.
He Tabitha and their daughter Naomi web living in a trailer outside of Bangor
and king was working two jobs.
He was teaching English at Hampton Academy and in the summers was pumping gas at
the local station while also working shifts at a laundromat.
Tabitha took shifts at a Dunkin donuts and they struggled to get by,
but it can always made time to write.
Even in the cramped quarters of the family's trailer,
he made a point to set aside space for a writing desk and the typewriter,
2000 words a day was his goal and that's the goal that he stands by today.
Eventually king earned two teaching certificates and was able to put his college
education to use as a teacher at Hampton Academy.
The work still wasn't what he wanted to be doing,
vote.
It was writing that he loved and writing,
but he wanted to honor.
Living from writing simply has always been his purpose in life as he explains.
There was nothing else I was made to do that was made to write stories and I
love to write stories.
That's why I do it.
I really can't imagine doing anything else and it's like cons.
Imagine and not doing what I do though it took years of effort.
His big break did come off the top of a fish,
the beginning of carry out of the trash.
In 1973 king finish the book and sent it off to a publisher.
He wasn't confident about its chances of being published,
saying,
my considered opinion was the diet written,
the world's all time loser.
The family wasn't doing well financially when he sent Carrie and then as they
couldn't even afford a phone,
so he got the news via telegram.
He'd be receiving a $2,500 advance and double date would be publishing carry.
Then even better news came.
The paperback rights were sold for $400,000 and without Kinkade,
quit teaching and begin writing full time and his family would be better off
than they ever debt to.
Imagine the book.
It was an absolute smash hits.
Within the next year,
a million copies were sold and only three years later it was made into an
academy award winning movie.
Stephen King was now officially a writer and an American celebrity,
but success did not mean the king settled into a completely untroubled life.
As he got to writing,
cranking out books like misery and pet cemetery,
he was drinking heavily and so he.
We had a problem.
Can they told rolling stone?
Nobody in the house drank,
but me,
my wife would have a glass of wine and that was all so I went into the garage
one night and the trashcan that was set aside for beer cans was full to the top.
It had been empty the week before.
I was drinking like a case of beer a night and I thought,
I'm an alcoholic.
That was probably 78,
79.
I thought,
I've got to be really careful because if somebody says you're drinking too much,
you have to quit.
I won't be able to.
He knew he had a problem,
but he didn't stop drinking.
In fact,
you took it one step further.
In the late seventies,
king started doing cocaine using this at night while he was writing.
By this time,
he and Tabitha had three kids and he knew his addictions.
We're taking a toll both on his family and on his writing.
He attributes the length of Tommy knockers to cocaine and looking back,
I said the book could have been half the length if so much of it had to been
inspired purely by his drugged up energy,
and he has also said that he doesn't even remember writing cue job so bad was
his consumption of alcohol and drugs during the eighties.
He says there's one novel Qj that I barely remember writing.
It's all I don't say that with pride or shame.
I knew with a vague sense of sorrow loss.
I liked that book.
I wish I could remember enjoying the good parts.
I put them down on the page in the shining and misery,
both carrie and undercurrent of his reference to his struggles.
Jack's Ahrens is an alcoholic and the shining and king has described the
antagonist of misery as essentially the personification of cocaine.
It wasn't until the late eighties when Tabitha threatened to leave him and the
family stage two dramatic intervention that king things off.
His acts of the intervention has family displayed drug paraphernalia,
orange pills that they had collected from the trash gang with the magnitude of
his problem laid out in front of his eyes and in front of his family and
friends,
made the decision to get sober.
Now he's been sober for nearly three decades during the 19 nineties and into the
21st century,
can continue to be one of the world's most prolific and the well known writers
is book spoons,
movies and miniseries,
and over 350 million copies of his books have been sold.
After it became so popular,
King took the step of publishing under a pseudonym,
Richard Bachman.
He wanted to see if he could still get books published and towns for themselves
without his now famous names splashed across the front.
It turns out well,
he totally could.
The first book he published under the name Richard Bachman was rage set in
gangs,
familiar weld of main high school.
The book tells the story.
You have a teenager who engages in violent acts at his school.
He sets his locker on fire.
She says,
Algebra teacher and the tax and other students with a wrench.
In 1977,
it was a figment of kings imagination,
but in the late eighties and nineties and nineties,
the book unfortunately started to resemble actual occurrences at schools across
the United States.
In 1997,
after a student's shot,
eight people at a prayer meeting in Kentucky,
it was discovered that he had a copy of rage and his locker disturbed by this
king lost his publisher to take the book out of Prince.
To this day,
rage remains out of friends
even as his success group king remain living in Maine.
The family owns a home in Bangor on a human level near the lakes.
For the summit,
it was near the home in level that king's life almost ended.
In 1999,
king was taking a walk along one of the winding would it roads that aren't so
familiar,
part of means landscape.
Then events smashed into him from behind was knocks off the roads and into a
ditch.
Witnesses said he was in a heap and it was clear his leg was broken.
His glasses flew off and landed in the van that hit him at the hospital.
We went to multiple surgeries and had to do physical therapy as a part of his
recovery.
Brian Smith,
the driver who hits King,
had a track record of driving infractions,
including a Dui.
The king accident was blamed on Smith as dog distracting him,
causing him to swerve into the author.
Smith received a six month jail sentence that was later suspended and had his
license revoked for a year.
King was pretty upset at this.
He wanted Smith's license revoked for life given his history of bad driving.
Only a year after the accident,
Smith was found dead in his trailer at the age of 43.
He died of a painkiller overdose and then the twist of fate that seems straight
out of a king novel.
He died on king's birthday.
September 21st kings sustained horrific injuries in the accident,
but resumed writing one a month after being released from the hospital.
He finished the highly regarded on writing and didn't do thousand.
The book was published like 2002.
King decided that he simply didn't have the strength to keep writing as he had
in the past where you had previously sat and typed for hours at a time,
it now person to sit for long periods.
Addiction had also become part of his life again.
After the accident,
he took oxygen,
comes in to deal with the pain from his injuries,
and he became addicted to it as he had a decade earlier.
It was able to overcome the addiction and to live life once again,
so belief,
but I think in lieu of the written word,
there's ultimately proved to be strong for his post accident injuries and
struggles and so king returns to his craft.
He has said this,
he literally needs to write in order to live and what would happen if you didn't
write?
Oh,
I'd be debt.
I would have drank myself to death old drug myself to death or committed suicide
or some goddamn thing.
Well,
since this accident he's published dozens of stories and books including Mr.
Mercedes do Mckee Eleven,
2163 and under the dome a die hard red sox fan.
Like so many of his New England,
Stephen King,
also Carrie wrote a book after the Red Sox,
2004 world series win faithful to die hard.
Boston red sox fans chronic the historic 2004 season shared the story of the
emotional roller coaster king and so many other red sox fans road throughout the
summer and fall of 2004 and a feather display of his eclectic interests and
abilities can dabbles in music he played,
gets off the rock bottom,
remainders of and he was other members you might recognize to you anytime Dave
Berry and migrating a few of the other celebrities who joined king on stage.
Even actually Carrie wrote a musical with John Mellencamp build as a southern
gothic supernatural musical ghost brothers of [inaudible] county opens and ran
for a month at the alliance theatre in Atlanta.
Can is now 70 years old,
but he hasn't run out of ideas.
In fact,
he and his son one just released a co written book in 2017.
Well,
he's incredibly wealthy.
He writes in sells books at a breathtaking pace,
but he doesn't use his wealth to amass stuff.
The antifa owned three houses,
two in Maine and one in Florida.
It's the house in Maine that is the most iconic located in Bangor.
It's a huge old Victorian surrounded by a wrought iron fence,
decorated with bats from the outside.
The house is exactly where one would expect Stephen King to live on the inside.
It has an indoor swimming pool and a huge on the ground library.
The houses are extravagance by everyday standards,
but they really all the primary way king prefers to spend money on himself and
Tabitha.
I'm not a clothes person.
I'm not a boat person.
We do have a house in Florida,
but we live in Maine for Christ's sake.
It's not like a trendy community or anything.
His houses are beautiful,
but they don't use all of his money so well.
What does he do with it all?
Well,
he gives it away my sleep more.
He invested in projects that support his interests and just community and music.
Fan King has also pat just radio stations in Maine,
a huge baseball fan.
He funded the construction of a little league field in Bangalore.
The field is now known as the field of screens,
a tip of the hat to the fields funder.
Together he and Tabitha run these Steven and Tabitha King Foundation,
libraries and colleges,
especially the University of Maine in the Bangor Public Library has benefited
from King's philanthropy means historical society,
far departments,
arts organizations and hospitals have also been beneficiaries of the kings.
In 1,801 speech at Vassar college king made his view on generosity and charity
clear to his audience.
Should you give away what you have?
Of course you should.
I want you to consider making your lives one long gift to others and why not?
All you have is on loan anyway.
All he wants to get asked at the getting place from the Maserati.
You may dream about the retirement fund some broker will trying to sell you on.
None of that is real well.
That last is what you pass on.
The rest is smoke and mirrors.
In that same speech,
he discussed natural resources and his dislike of the George W dot Bush
administration with the advent of twitter in the years to follow king has an
even wider audience to share his political views with.
He's taken on president trump,
vice,
which are announcing that the president wasn't allowed to see the new version of
it when it hit theaters in 2017.
He is also made clear in very profane language and repeat it here,
what he thinks of the president and his administration.
Stephen King is a national figure in his own right.
For 30 years,
he has been affecting the conversation around pop culture.
His books sell by the millions and his movies rake in millions of dollars and
win Academy Awards.
Growing up,
he knew he wanted to write,
but he never wanted to do it.
To achieve the wealth and fame,
he's now a mast is reasoning is much simpler and it remains his mentor.
To this day,
writing isn't about making money,
getting famous,
getting dates,
getting laid,
or making friends.
In the end,
it's about enriching the lives of those who will read your work and enriching
your own life as well.
For over three decades from his home,
tucked away in the northeast corner of the United States,
Stephen King has been able to live out his childhood dream to write for a
living.
In doing so,
he's brought many of us nightmares,
the nightmares,
the world gladly welcomed as we continue to delve into his stories,
so I really hope you found that video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and do not forget to subscribe for
brand new videos just like this everyday of the week.
Also over there on the right,
check out some of our stuff from the archives,
all the great people that you might want to watch biographies of,
and as always,
thank you for watching.